catastrophic tornadoes tearing through
the Midwest and the south at least six
people were killed including two in
Arkansas where the governor has declared
a state of emergency and activated the
National Guard in Central Indiana three
people were also killed when a tornado
touched down late Friday evening in
Sullivan County the powerful storm swept
across the state and leveled homes and
crushed cars the storm also left a trail
of Destruction in Illinois Missouri
Tennessee and Iowa and the threat is not
over yet according to the National
Weather Service more than 28 million
people remain under tornado watch today
Roxanna severi is in Davenport Iowa with
the latest on all of this Roxanna good
morning
good morning Jeff the winds are still
going strong here in Iowa as authorities
assess the damage from the tornadoes
that ripped across the state yesterday
there were evacuations and rescues but
this massive nearly 900 mile long storm
system brought deaths in at least three
states
pretty good
one person was killed and dozens more
hurt when a tornado plowed into a
crowded theater in Belvedere Illinois
more than 250 people were attending a
heavy metal concert when the Twister
collapsed the building about 70 miles
Northwest of Chicago it's crazy to think
I've gone to so many shows here I know
so many friends who go here all the time
and it's crazy to think that the roof
caved in an afternoon tornado also
shredded Little Rock Arkansas it touched
down in the western part of the capital
city leveling homes in a shopping center
meteorologists described the storm as
catastrophic Witnesses describe a
fast-moving high pressure storm weather
warning came on and then the lights went
out then we heard everybody running
downstairs and it came over and the
pressure in my ears dropped and it got
really weird it was devastating it was
uh I say if you was in an airplane and
had to take a higher attitude and your
ears seems like they're about to blow
that's what it felt like it was a lot of
pressure it was quick though at least
two people were killed in Wynne Arkansas
just to the west of Memphis the tornado
flattened the town's high school and
left residents there without power two
tornadoes on the ground storms hammered
communities like this all throughout the
nation's midsection on Friday and they
come less than a week after a tornado
killed at least 21 people in Rolling
Fork Mississippi President Biden visited
that Community Friday promising help as
you fight through this you're not alone
the American people
will be with you
they'll help you through it and so alive
the president announced the government
will pay 100 percent of the recovery as
well as shelter and cleanup costs for
the next 30 days in Rolling Fork but now
of course this latest line of storms
will mean even more people in more
places need help Nancy
Roxanna thank you